hi there Steve Kaufman here today I'm
going to talk about Netflix language
learning and the coronavirus now there
is a relationship between Netflix and
language learning there's no real
relationship with either of them and the
coronavirus except I'm going to talk
about it a bit in this video
Netflix okay so I'm working on my Arabic
for the time being I've decided to focus
in on Arabic I put my Farsi my Persian a
little bit on the back burner I'm gonna
get back to it it's not far away I
sometimes do look at it but I want to
really delve into this Arabic because I
find it all fascinating so what I've
been doing is because my wife likes
watching movies on Netflix and she had
been watching movies on in Turkish which
got me into Turkish but I put that on
the back burner and she likes me to sit
there with her and watch these Netflix
movies and normally I'm not that
interested but I said okay if we get
some Arabic ones then I will sit there
so we saw an Egyptian Arabic movie
called this evening and it was really
good I really enjoyed it was clever it
was witty it was there was suspense so
that was fun and then we found an Arabic
at least a Lebanese one and it was
called tango and we didn't like that at
all
it was lie there is like certain amount
of violence and it just didn't I like
the kind of family-oriented ones where
you sort of go back and you find the
same cast of characters some of the
early Turkish ones we saw we're a bit
like that like Baba John I think was one
and sorry joining your family members
every evening and getting into their
language world and so we didn't like
tango but then so we stopped watching it
and but then we found one called
what is it called again unit is a writer
really fun again a bit of a mystery
thing humorous family involvements and
stuff like that and so now of course the
Lebanese movies are in Levantine Arabic
the Egyptian one is an Egyptian Arabic
and there are other videos out there
from Kuwait and elsewhere presumably so
I've been working on my mini stories in
Levantine Arabic and I find now that I'm
able to understand more and more of the
Lebanese movie which is fun which is
really fun and even where I don't
understand it I think watching something
in Netflix where you're getting 20 30 40
% of times you're able to follow on you
have the impression that you're in there
you're part of them and that's
tremendously motivating it really gets
me back to going through my Levantine
many stories and when I am comfortable
with them I move on to other material it
is amazing when you go over many stories
and I've gone through them I was going
to look up how many times I've listened
to them 20 30 times it's amazing the
things that you don't notice the first
second third fifth tenth time and then
you notice it the 15th time so I find it
always worthwhile to go back I gradually
what I'm doing now is I'm I'm going
through all of the yellow saved links in
each lesson sort of flash card in them
then going back in and listening to the
lesson and I know from experience that
if I can work those yellow links which
now for some of the more recent lessons
is still 30 40 50 words that I have
saved them that I don't yet know if I
can get them down to 5 6 8 then I'm
really going to be you know in a good
position in a position to move forward
the disadvantage of course with Arabic
is that there are these different
versions of the language so you can't at
least I'm not aware of where I could get
an e-book and the corresponding audio
book all written in say Levantine Arabic
or Egyptian Arabic whatever is written
is going to be in Standard Arabic and
the words are different the
pronunciation is different not totally
different there's a lot of common things
so that makes it a little bit difficult
on the other hand it's fun it's fun to
discover this world the relationship
between Levantine Arabic and Egyptian
Arabic and Standard Arabic and and to
kind of get into that whole thing so
that's what I'm doing so I'm finding
Netflix now we have a were you know a
browser extension for Netflix where we
can bring in the subtitles but the
subtitles for
Lebanese or the Egyptian films are in
standard Arabic so that's really not
what I'm hearing so there are no
materials with that I'm aware of with
subtitles in say Levantine Arabic so you
know if there are on YouTube or
somewhere please let me know but I
haven't found them so you know I'm gonna
be in a bit of a problem here once I
finish the mini stories to try to move
to some other material which will be
interesting and yet not too difficult
but in say Levantine or Egyptian Arabic
I'm in no hurry
Arabic isn't going anywhere I can spend
years enjoying my exploration of Arabic
our person or Turkish so but Netflix is
key Netflix I think is a wonderful
resource for language learners obviously
if the subtitles the dialogue and the
subtitles is the same as the spoken
language then we can use the web but our
browser extension bring it into link
study that as a lesson and then actually
improve our comprehension that's not
something I'm able to do with with
Arabic now just a brief word on the
coronavirus you know I saw the it was
Memorial Day in the United States it's
kind of like our Remembrance Day here in
Canada a solemn occasion where we
remember people who sacrifice themselves
in wartime and I see there are lots of
demonstrations people upset about the
lockdown and so forth and so on I have
trouble understanding these people the
coronavirus from my understanding here
in BC we have had I think it's 150
deaths for a population of five million
so that's a relatively low number and I
think most people here have confidence
in the health authorities we have a
wonderful spokesperson dr. Barney Henry
very calm very knowledgeable answer his
questions calmly and has had a bit of a
softer hand in terms of what we're
allowed to do and not allowed to do
which has been possible because the
thing has been kind of
under control we get a flare-up in an
old folks home or a poultry plant and
they're able to shut it down very
quickly so there's not the kind of I
don't know polarization here the odd
person mumbling but nothing serious
something like I think ninety-four
percent of the coronavirus deaths in
Canada are in two provinces Ontario and
Quebec which together account for about
60% of the population but 94 percent of
the deaths Quebec has been hit
particularly hard why is it that some
places are hit harder than others it's
it's one of the many things that we
don't know enough about you know
apparently the the incidence the
coronavirus in Ontario and Quebec came
primarily from the United States didn't
come from China here in British Columbia
we had people flying in from China from
Iran back in say January February who
were identified and asked to corner you
know isolate themselves and so that I
think was controlled fairly well then we
had some community spread in the in the
old folks homes but Ontario Quebec
obviously pretty bad not as bad as New
York not as bad as Spain and and Italy
and if we see what happened you know the
the like I saw that there was a borough
in New York City it might have been
Queens that has a total population of
550,000 and they had like 800 deaths so
you know if you have that degree of
death in your community that's 800
deaths for 550,000 people as opposed to
say BC with 150 deaths and five million
people I mean if you're living with that
amount of death as they had in Italy as
they had in Spain then the response has
to be totally drastic because people are
not going to tolerate their hospitals
overflowing you know lack of you know
coffins lack of space and the funeral
homes and so forth so if in fact the
actions of people caused this virus to
flare up again there will be very
very strict markdowns I don't care where
you are as long as it stays below a
certain level you can pretend that it's
not a serious threat however if we look
at how widespread it is right now like
in Canada something like 4% of people
who are tested are positive and there
are only testing people who have
symptoms I think in BC the numbers like
2 to 3 percent of the P and again only
testing people who either are positive
or our health care workers or work in
old folks homes or where there's an
outbreak in a prison or you know you
know you know poultry plant or whatever
so that's so that the actual spread
within the community is probably you
know single digits 1 2 3 4 % that's all
that has it if you go to an area where
they've had a severe yes it's a severe
serious you know spread like Italy or
New York City they had some numbers
there that was like 10 15 % that's all I
think in Sweden where in theory they've
allowed been allowed to do whatever they
want was in fact their behavior he's
still very much you know
reduced activity reduced mobility
compared to pre Koba days I saw
somewhere where in Stockholm the
infection rate was like 7 or 8 percent
so if we assume that that eventually 70
percent of the population is gonna get
it if herd immunity is 70 percent we're
at 3 4 5 7 10 percent like even the
hardest hit areas they're at 10 percent
we got a long way to go in the in the
coronavirus we should be very very
careful and particularly when I see
people gathering in large groups you
know as dr. bonnie bonnie henry
explained we don't want people she
doesn't want people getting together
with 20 or 30 or 50 other people because
she's responsible for contact tracing so
if you're with five six other people and
one of those people is infected and we
that out then she or her group of
contact tracers only have to trace those
10 people or six people and each one of
them might have also been with another
group of four or five six whoever you
know was infected but if it's 50 then
they haven't got a chance to follow
those cases and trace them and you know
the likelihood is if you're with a group
a large group I remember probability
from high school I don't really remember
it but I do remember that in order to
get two people with the same birth date
okay and there's 365 days in the year
you only need like 23 people so while
theoretically 3% of the population has
it if you get 50 people together there's
a strong likelihood that five six eight
percent of the people there in that
particular gathering have it so even one
person having it in that group spreading
it to 50 people who in turn can spread
it to 50 people gives you this
exponential growth and if you get the
exponential growth you will get the same
thing that they had in New York City or
you know berry go mobile on and then
there will be like very severe lockdowns
again so why would people deliberately
you know run the risk of that happening
I just I don't understand the mentality
I see that even here in Canada there's a
one professor in Toronto has feels he
has an antibody serum that can increase
the immunity of older people so
obviously if we can increase the ability
of older people who are you know 60 70
80 depending on which country
overwhelming majority of people who die
from this if we can increase the ability
of older people to resist the corona
virus without having to be on a you know
respirator for example obviously this is
going to improve the ability of the
hospital system to cope there will be
other treatment treatments that come
along will gradually get better at how
to operate and yet limit the spread we
gradually get better at treatment we may
have a vaccine at some point
we get better methods for tracing people
so our ability to deal with this is
going to improve over time so why
wouldn't you do everything possible to
prevent a rapid spread now when we're so
early in our learning curve on what the
virus is how does the deal with it how
to test for it and all these other
things we will have much better testing
systems better supplies of these tests
better supplies of PPE you know personal
protective equipment hopefully I know
that again I was golfing with a couple
and this fellow's daughter-in-law was at
the University of British Columbia and
they're totally committed to being
prepared for the next spike the next
wave which they expect to come in
September hopefully it doesn't come but
they have to be prepared and we have to
be better prepared then than we were for
the first occasion so I just say I
always wear a mask I wear a mask I
decided that way back I assume I'm gonna
behave as if I have it I wear a mask it
doesn't cost anything to wear a mask I
can't believe the amount of of political
bickering going on on the subject of
wearing a mask just wear a mask because
it's not worth it to spread this disease
and see another spike so you know we are
going to have more pandemics this isn't
the last one they had the plague during
the Middle Ages you know we're the same
people and there's all the same kinds of
dangers out there so I just think people
should be as responsible as they can be
and hopefully we'll have some advances
come along that make us better able to
cope with this with this virus meanwhile
I will go back
learning Arabic I gotta work on my
Levantine Arabic today so that I can
understand more of the writer my
Lebanese movie and I hear a bit of a
ramble thanks for listening
[Music]